all right yo
bootleg podcast special guest in here um
we got the hottest artist in la right
now
damn that's heavy bro his name is blast
what's the deal man what's up man it's
crazy because dj head
has been telling me about you for so
long my co-host
and i remember him and uh salas talking
about you
and i guess dj had tried to sign you or
or approached you to hell i don't know
yeah but he was like yo black's the only
guy i ever tried to like work with
right yeah he told me that too uh shout
out dj head that's good people always
giving good advice
um yeah we definitely sat down before
and had some
some talks give me some of your
background man like like where are you
from in l.a because a lot of you know
that
i heard i i see you rocking the cranshaw
hat sometimes
like where are you from in the city so i
just say i'm from la
um i grew up on the east side of l.a
75th and central okay
over there by fremont high then i moved
to inglewood
and then uh high school years i moved to
the ie with my dad oh [ __ ] so you're
just like
yeah l.a through and through yeah that's
crazy yeah
so you're man your [ __ ] is so fire bro i
i first
like tapped in with you uh the bino
project you guys
dropped the joint tape together which is
[ __ ] la classic
um but give me some of your background
as an artist like how long have you been
making music man like
like when did this [ __ ] become your job
like okay
this is what i'm gonna do now like yeah
i mean i would say fresh out of high
school i started
producing and recording myself
simultaneously
so i was just teaching myself on youtube
um
[ __ ] with fl studio and in pro tools
and download
downloading different programs just
teaching myself and i fell in love with
it this was probably like eight years
ago
so yeah so okay so you're you record
yourself
yeah you make beats yeah you sing
yeah do you mix and master yeah
so you're like [ __ ] rust 2.0
you're like la's russ just the one
[ __ ] stop shop
you're keeping all the money yeah i do
my um
my cover art too and most of my post
production on my videos
wait you do your cover art yeah your yo
your your ep
artwork was fire and good looking shout
out ep on my eagle team
she uh creatively put that together that
shit's dope man so
um so you kind of became a master of the
craft
just every aspect of it um what was your
like childhood
like like what like were you you know
how did you grow up
like did you play any [ __ ] sports
what were you doing like as a kid
prior to music as a kid we was just
running around just
figuring [ __ ] out i remember like the
first thing come to my mind is riding
bikes with my friends
that was the best right throwing rocks
at house having pegs
right just a little badge yo hop on the
back tire bruh exactly we mobbing
yeah i mean it was cool until you get
older you realize like
certain locations you're not supposed to
go to and stuff like that territories
and
yeah it kind of changed my perspective
as i grew up but um yeah that was part
of the reason why my mom wanted me to go
to the ie
with my dad to get away from that that
life exactly
was uh going how how much of a
because a lot of people who aren't from
the l.a area they'll hear someone from
riverside
they'll be like oh that's la yeah okay
what's the big difference culturally you
think
like from what you were like before your
mom sent you to
to uh i.e like what what changed the
most
just me knowing everybody in the
neighborhood really like everybody more
today's self out there when i was at
late younger it's like
everybody's more outside and vocal and
you know everybody on your block you
know i'm saying out there was just like
everybody today so so i would say that's
the most
change that i've seen um do you remember
the first time
one of your records like
like hit us like like do you remember
like your first like
song that got moving online like what
was like was it something when you were
in high school like what was like like
even if it was like just the homies were
like oh [ __ ]
like people really like my music even if
it's like 30 of them like yeah
nah for sure i remember i used to put
songs on myspace back in the day
shout out to myspace you know who's in
your top eight though real quick
damn i don't even remember that's that's
a good question are they still around
would they still be in your nobody from
my top eight still around to this day
now that wasn't a solid top eight then
uh
definitely so you had us you were
putting music up on myspace
right and um i feel like will reinsured
me to keep
to keep making music was girls used to
upload my songs when they paid you know
how you can yeah you could pick
someone else's yeah exactly so i used to
think that was cool i used to think i
was somebody because they were
awesome if you if you had the song
choice on your myspace page it was so
important that's all
that's all the credit you needed back
then i would put way too much thought
into which songs i would have as like my
two or three on my space or like yo when
people come to my page i want them to
know
how raw rap [ __ ] i'm into i want them to
know how to be [ __ ] with the boom bap
[ __ ] exactly that was your whole
personality
let me put this [ __ ] this this re-up
gang pusha t
[ __ ] on my page you know what i'm saying
some people know like i'm with the
[ __ ] with the nelly [ __ ]
exactly no that's crazy so how old are
you
i'm uh 15. you're 15 okay well how
where did you graduate high school uh
2010 okay for sure
i graduated no five so so yeah i'm just
trying to judge the era of music you
came up
so you obviously
are uh like i mean sonically man
you can do anything i feel like um
your melodies are crazy appreciate where
you think you get that from
um damn that's a good ass question i
probably would say
just growing up in my house my mom and
my older sister
just would play anything you know from
erica badu to jill scott
but like that's where some good [ __ ]
yeah my melodic side came from
and that's what really attracts to me
the most like melody
yeah like and i feel like two like
melodies are
the heart people you know i hear a lot
of people talking about like today's
music is more melodic than like in the
90s or the 2000s but it's like
i feel like the melody part is the
hardest part like you
like you can anybody can write a bunch
of lyrics on a page
and then they open their mouth and they
sound god awful
right that's part of the reason why like
when i'm recording i just like to go
with whatever i'm feeling because when
you write it
it's not the exact same as you would
perform it you know i'm saying
that makes sense so is that your process
when you're recording are you like
just feeling the melody out yeah i would
literally literally just say a melody
with no words like
to a beat and then fill the words and
and then as it goes yeah
exactly yeah i mean i i've been in the
studio a lot i feel like a lot of people
are kind of
that's kind of like the the way to
record now because i feel like like you
said writing it down is like
it's like you're reciting something and
uh i mean i mean especially with me
having a studio in my house
it gives me the opportunity to take my
time with it too so not to say like i'm
just freestyling everything but
i really like to take my time and find
what feels good versus what sounds good
okay so outside of you and the myspace
moment what was the first record of
yours like a what
like like i know that the bino project
made a lot of waves and before that you
were making some noise but
what was that record that kind of put
you on in the city where you were kind
of like okay like
you know this shit's going the right
direction um
damn that's a good i wouldn't even say
it was one record
it's just a buy i know you're dropping a
lot yeah it was a slow build
up until the point where where i put out
until i put out the six tape and i was
like okay
i had uh this record called savage would
be no
that was the one that really like caught
everybody's attention
and i was on beano's sorry for the
weight tape
yeah so you and beno by the way bino's
project outside is super slept on
go check that [ __ ] out father you're on
you're uh
you're yeah the single is crazy we was
running that [ __ ] up on the radio
for for at least a month man shout out
that record is crazy thank you um
how did your guys's friendship like
start up
so uh it's this artist y'all may know
his name caitlyn for real for real
shout out to kaelin yeah uh i produced
this song he got called right with it
of course and uh beno hit up caitlyn
like yo who did this
you know didn't even know i was an
artist at the time okay a lot of people
know me from producing
so um yeah caitlyn exchanged our
contacts
i send beno probably like five beats and
he recorded every one in like
like a week wow and sent them back but
he was dropping them too and putting
videos out to him and it was all going
viral
like you know on youtube right so um
yeah he started putting together sorry
for the weight tape i sent them
savage and he ended up putting that on
on
sorry for the weight and then we also
ended up putting that on six
tape right and that's how we started our
relationship
that's crazy because um
it's it's like like you guys recently
just started [ __ ] with each other but
chemistry's fire i don't know what it is
but just
his workflow is just like mine so it was
easy we clicked
right off the gym do you feel like um
like you said earlier like you're you're
like
you're come up and it's still you're
still in the middle of it
but like the slow grind aspect of it
was was it ever like frustrating or like
were you ever
hitting walls in the music industry
where you kind of like
almost like threw in the hat nah yeah
you definitely had those moments but
i don't know i feel like me being able
to produce my
my own sound kept me like
humble enough to believe that sooner or
later it was going to work
you know i'm saying i looked at it like
i'm just developing my sound
instead of like when is she gonna blow
like i feel like i was just like all
right
like he was getting your reps up right
he was in the dk yeah yeah
it's gonna hit that's fair man damn so
the ep
is uh it's fire straight through and
through man
i was um i was just talking to my homie
from new york about it
because all people be hitting me like yo
what's what's going on in l.a and then i
gotta usually hit up dj head
but nah i mean uh the ep from you from
arizona i'm from phoenix yeah
that's you yeah that's cool we've never
met which is crazy
because i yeah but um uh what was i
[ __ ] saying i'm high
i was talking ahead
oh you're ep we're talking about your ep
yeah ep's crazy
i was extremely cause i felt like every
time i was talking to anybody
uh it was like i've talked to people at
def jam like and they're bringing your
name up
like everybody's trying to sign this
fool this was before this was like
around the time bino dropped this
project but
everybody had already kind of known like
you're the guy that's next up
um you signed with red bull which is
very
unconventional i know warren brew was
[ __ ] with red bull
and yeah um why why what
kind of give us the rundown on that
decision because it definitely caught me
by surprise
so i'm um i'm signed under my own
airplane which is eagle and we did a
partnership with red bull
so um yeah basically eagle is my team
that
right put together and uh right now it's
just like a management because i'm the
only artist that they focus on
got you and uh well red bull yeah
everybody be saying like why are you
doing
why you go with red bull i wanted to go
to unconventional route because this was
my first
time doing paperwork with anybody so i
wanted to be strategic and i didn't want
it to
be something where it's like a long
situation you know what i'm saying i
wanted to do something where i can learn
the ropes and things
and it was the perfect fit for me
because they understood
my position and my value as being a
producer as well
so i feel like yeah it was the perfect
situation it's a short-term
it's a short-term deal so are you
technically a free agent now
um i'm not gonna say that because i do
wanna i got some plans that i'm not
speaking on right now but so you've
already signed the ma the big big deal
[Laughter]
i know i've heard some people trying to
get at you is it everybody
a lot of people have been tapping there
but i'm just trying to take my time with
it like
yeah like i feel like uh the mistake
most people
make is like you're like
you're doing what you're supposed to be
doing if a major label
got involved tomorrow like it might
speed up like
some things yeah but you're you're like
there's not a lot of major label can
bring to the table that you're not
already
yeah besides money and that's going to
come that's a fact but
even um like red bull they definitely
helped
crazy like with my situation like just
with the publications and everything
helping me put together
my rollout oh they was really on their
[ __ ] every idea we came up with
they was they was down to produce it or
you know figure out ways they can be a
part of it
i mean that company is very they're they
do a lot of dope dope [ __ ] that's like
people obviously equate it to an energy
drink but
they do so much ill [ __ ] nah yeah they
fire [ __ ] with red bull
records absolutely [ __ ] with red bull
records
and only drink red bull because it gives
you wings
do you get free red bull for life i hope
so i mean
i'm assuming you have cases no yeah they
definitely blessed me with the cases
which is lovely but yeah i don't know if
i get it for life though
there's like a red bull airplane
competition have you seen that
they got so many sports it's so many oh
no but they have like a competition with
these [ __ ] airplanes doing crazy ass
[ __ ] bro it's like
like well like tricks bro yeah it's like
wild
from like the highest yeah i've seen
that [ __ ] red bull man
they were raging over there yeah
everything extreme they're part of it
that's [ __ ] crazy um talk about man just
like
i know you've had a lot of of of people
tap in with you like
um like i said you're you're kind of the
known
i feel like it's the consensus amongst
the tastemakers out here is like you're
up next
who's tapped in that's like kind of
surprised you that was somebody who you
were
a fan of or somebody who you were like
oh my god this person knows who the [ __ ]
i am
it's funny that you said it earlier russ
tapped in recently russ
yeah russ a great guy solid dude he
shouted me out on twitter too
i saw that yeah i just saw that you're
right yeah
he just tweeted about you like too it
was yesterday the day before yeah yeah
shout out to russ that's crazy because i
watch all his interviews and i'll be
feeling exactly how he'd be feeling
about everything so
shout out russ sean love because he
didn't have to do that
you know it's interesting with russ i
feel like he gets so much unwarranted
hate
and i'm like yo this guy's literally
giving you guys priceless
game that's crazy for free like [ __ ] you
can't pay for [ __ ] that nobody want to
tell you
who could tell you and he's just
spreading the game to everybody
and it's like yo you could do nothing
but appreciate somebody like that too
does that kind of um
staying independent or or or not
necessarily
going like the super major label route
to somebody like russ and what he you
know when he posted his tomb core [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was crazy
come on yeah that's pure motivation for
me when he even when he tapped in i was
telling her i was like bro this is just
reinsurance that i'm on the right path
yeah things like that yeah that's what
motivate me for show
um you have a
crazy uh record with mazza you guys just
dropped the video for
um are you prepared to be the next like
hook guy
i think ty's gonna pass you the baton
hey i'm not mad at that i'm not mad at
that yeah i definitely take that role
i'm not mad at being the hood guy i feel
like it's coming man
i do too i feel like it's like i feel
like you're like ty dolla sounds gonna
be like
[Laughter]
yeah ty got it for sure yeah yeah on
twitter that's the trend they say blast
don't matter bro everyone's coming at
you like yeah bro you got to like
man um who's your dream collaboration
like who's like that one artist
that even no matter how unrealistic it
is like
that that you want you want to work with
people probably gonna make fun of me but
i say chris brown hey
i feel like chris brown is untouchable
any anything he touched it just turned
into go
i just had a conversation with you know
who gashy is the singer gashy
no so we had a conversation about how
chris brown in my opinion
is the most talented artist to ever that
i've ever seen
and when i'm talking talent i'm not
talking about i mean he could sing and
he could dance better than everybody but
he could also paint your house
right and like he does murals and
man not human i mean he's obviously got
his flaws with all our flaws you know
he's just much more public but god damn
if he don't got more attention this
[ __ ] could hit a jumper
that's a fact when he did that backflip
on stage and they was comparing him to
michael jackson
and yeah and and fair point he'll
probably take
99 of everybody's wife's he's chris
brown that's a talent
you know gotta give it to him um
yeah i'm gonna put i think you working
with chris brown has got to happen in
the next 12 months i feel like
absolutely
it's happened i feel like that you could
kind of you could kind of put that in
like like in the atmosphere it's gonna
happen yeah i'm gonna manifest that for
sure
chris brown i'm gonna work with you come
on what about somebody like super
unexpected
soda baby's a nickelback fan which was
[ __ ] weird
um that's the worst band ever
i would say somebody like adele ah shout
out to adele man
yeah i think everything she make is just
big like stadium well her music is like
obviously she just became a meme shout
out to her for representing that's funny
on jamaica day
but no but like her music is like
timeless it's like
it's like [ __ ] that like she's a living
legend for sure
do you think you sing do you think when
someone loses weight like that
does their voice change i don't know
that's a good question
i think i think her voice is the same oh
i mean i don't know
i don't think we've heard skinny adele
yet i don't think she's dropped some
[ __ ] since she's
she's uh been on her fitness shout out
to her though
um is there going to be a sequel to you
and be no [ __ ]
absolutely i mean i can't speak on beano
be happy well no he told me yes but you
know i just want to see okay
oh yeah it's it's a hundred percent a
goal in my hand how many records you
guys have together that are in
in the can if any um
i probably say like a cool 10
10 yeah okay that's i mean that's a
project there you go
yeah but you know the vibes we got we
got to lock in for sure
for on a real note oh by the way
i i heard this new [ __ ] so you probably
heard with the big rapper on it oh
i ain't heard it yet oh shout out to him
he's got some heat comes
crazy um yeah is
when you make a ep do you have
because your debut album is going to be
very very important
right like it's like a moment for
everybody but for you specifically i
think it's going to mean a lot
and um when you separate like all right
now this has got to be on the album
yeah absolutely i got some records right
now that i
know for sure is like all right this is
going to be on the album
that i recorded probably like two years
ago like nah this one's got to make the
album like this is timeless records that
you come across yeah you gotta
tuck those for sure um
has has uh has roddy tapped in with you
at all i've been on roddy for a minute
now
um i actually produced one record for
him it's not out though
okay but yeah roddy that's the on me so
you guys have already had a relationship
yeah absolutely his his melodies are
also
i think he's got the best melodies in
the game right he's
the way he be skating on his verses i'm
like jesus it's like a
soulful trap singer yo it's [ __ ]
crazy yo look man
quick break from the podcast and tell
you about odd socks all right they're
our official sponsor they support what
we do here at the bootleg kit podcast
all right they got the nickelodeon
joints they got these uh
yo shout out to ghostbusters i might
keep those um anyway
what you gotta do is hit that
oddsoxofficial.com
if you want to support what i do the
bootleghead podcast then support our
partners odd socks go buy some socks man
holidays are coming up odd
socksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev you're getting 20
off of the most comfortable socks in the
world
shout out to odd socks it's i saw
glasses malone tweet something that the
future of west coast hip-hop is very it
it
lies a lot on on whether or not it's on
you essentially i mean
i forget what he said i know she's
talking about that i try to sort through
glasses [ __ ]
sports takes and gets something good and
he said something about like the future
of west coast music
depends a lot on on me on your success
when you saw that like that i mean you
know glasses of og out here like
that's a lot of you know that's a lot to
carry a lot to handle especially in my
position but
i just look at it as like
i don't know i'm just grateful you know
at the end of the day like i can't
really
i don't really like to brag or nothing
like i'm i'm humble like i keep
everything not too high not too low yeah
when i see stuff like that it's just
reinsurance for me like i said earlier
just like damn that's big like g malone
is a legend
shout out to glasses man he's also just
a very very uh he's like the skip
bayless of hip-hop
if you ever want to follow someone on
twitter and want to break your [ __ ]
computer screen just follow glasses
at g malone that's my boy um
what do you do like like give me some
some some you know let's like dive in
like what are you doing like
in your spare time bro like when you
ain't [ __ ] being a musical genius and
[ __ ]
and like and trying to take my job on
real 923 when i was on vacation
yeah i saw that um but now uh what do
you like what are you into man like you
watch [ __ ]
like what kind of movies like you play
video games um
yeah i mean of course i play video games
call of duty 2k
something that people don't know i like
sometimes i watch cartoon i like the
avatar avatar cartoon
yeah that's the uh the anime right yeah
they the movie wasn't good nah they're
like real life movie
you talk about the the one with the like
the blue
no no no no no i mean the [ __ ] they
did an anime version of the
the airbender [ __ ] oh i don't know i
don't remember it oh it was like a real
life it was it was horrible yeah i know
something but i heard the
i'm not into it my son's into all the
naruto and yeah yeah you [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] nah i don't [ __ ]
remember that's like another error for
me but but the avatar
yeah i'm sorry that's my [ __ ] do you
ever watch that show where they be in
the middle of the [ __ ] forest
and they have to survive for like i
think i know what you're talking about
they're like on the island
bro there's this show called it's on
amazon prime or netflix
that [ __ ] is crazy they're like dropped
off is it called lost
maybe yeah it is called lost and they
got to survive off the land
that [ __ ] is crazy i feel like you have
to be caucasian to do
i don't know man i just feel like it's
like they just like
by the way i'm white so it's just some
white people [ __ ] like who's getting
dropped off in the middle of the desert
like
voluntarily like like that's some whole
other [ __ ] i couldn't be a part of
um i'm sorry
i don't know i don't want to get
cancelled for being racist
[Laughter]
[ __ ] is real like yo this this
if i don't know dog i'm high as [ __ ]
anyway
other collaborations we talked about you
being the hook guy you said yeah
i could see that which means that you're
definitely gonna be on some [ __ ] that's
already been recorded coming out
but like what are you already having it
tucked like hook wise i know
you're gonna very shortly people aren't
gonna be able to afford the feature but
you know right now um i just did some
[ __ ] with tyga
um and i also did some [ __ ] arrests
recently
tiger and russ yeah well separately but
yeah yeah i don't want to hear a tiger
in wrestling
i'd like to hear i'm just being honest i
don't want to hear them
together on the song i'd like to hear
you want a song with tigers right right
right i wouldn't want to hear tyga on a
song with tiger though
i'd like like you'd have to be on it for
me to like shout out to tiger though
last kings you know what i'm saying
um how did you tyga i mean no tiger's a
legend let's not get it [ __ ] up
but how did you and tiger get get
together so you just reached out tapped
in and now he tapped in on instagram
he was just like let's work and i was
like damn that's crazy a lot of people
be tapping in e40 reached out
you got you know what you always got to
give 40 the feature man that's
comfortable that's automatic e40 come on
you ever see
like look at the track list on e40s
albums and you'll see all the features
and you'll be like nobody has ever told
the 40 no for the future
because he'd be having everybody on his
[ __ ]
no matter how big that it's like yo no
he's got it
e40s album [ __ ] tracklist first of
all they're like 80 songs
it full drop a triple disc on you bro
nah but one thing about e40 he one of
the artists
it's a few of them that never have a
weak verse oh never
mizzy another one of them oh forever
yo that's crazy mazzy has never had a
weak verse ever
and e40 is one of the greatest of all
time i think he's on a west coast
uh when you do the round mount rushmore
he's the only bay representative up
there
um shout out to 40 man 40 water is a
legend damn so e40 is tapped in russ so
you and russ have actually done a
like the record exists for you or for
him
uh both so you guys you guys do too yeah
little trade-off
something like that okay is that gonna
be the one that you tucked like okay
this is an album one
um i'm having debates with peru right
now i'm trying to put it on the deluxe
for no level
oh [ __ ] hey honestly it might be a
moment right man honestly
especially because he just tweeted about
you right now are you trying to put it
on the album or the
or or the deluxe of the ep i want to put
it on the deluxe
once i once i got something i'm ready to
go hey i'm voting for that because i
like to hear it
yeah but your boy probably
talks it's still in talks [ __ ]
and then the bino [ __ ] is just you guys
it's it's crazy because now you guys are
like
he's on def jam now you you got your
situation is it harder to like
does the business get any more difficult
for you guys to do some [ __ ] together
as opposed to like when y'all did the
first one or it's like yo let's just put
the [ __ ] out because nobody can tell us
any different
nah i mean yeah it's the only thing i
would say is different is just signing
papers now
i'm saying but it's the same workflow
yeah same workflow have you ever
switched up out of fruity loops
yeah i mean i messed with um ableton i
messed with reason
i feel like yeah that's like you could
tell a lot about a producer sometimes
like when you know like what they're
what they use yeah you know what i'm
saying i feel like ableton is a
is fire yeah you get more flexibility
like ableton for sampling and stuff
ransom from 1500 put me on
hey what's in shout out to 1500 to
nothing man shout out to rants
um do you have any idea when you're
gonna drop
well the deluxe obviously is coming soon
i'm assuming
yeah um no no specific date but i plan
to drop
it late october early november besides
russ is there going to be any other
features on the deluxe there's got to be
right
yeah like who
man just don't want out there bro i mean
i already mentioned his name earlier but
you mentioned his name earlier yeah
i still want people to anticipate oh you
turned my tiger yeah
but i still want people to anticipate me
even doing features wait so tiger's
gonna be on your deluxe
fire shout out to tyga man
that's lit yo he's been he'd be you know
i tapped in
man not yet tiger got his ears to the
streets that was crazy i wasn't
expecting for him to even
know who i was that's crazy
your relationship with bino um did that
start
after nip it passed or around that time
it was right before right before i was
gonna ask you if you ever had any
interactions with nip
i met nip one time at the uh rex in the
middle video shoot actually
oh [ __ ] okay um you know keefa yeah of
course
yeah he introduced me to nip and um yeah
i told him
like i worked close with beno he was
like yeah he already know i'm locked in
with being a
damn that's crazy that's it's terrible
it would've been crazy to hear you guys
do some [ __ ] together
man legendary [ __ ] yeah who
who's uh have you ever have you had any
artists
try to sign you yet not a like you know
how they're there's
there's artists that have their
situations couple artists trying to sign
me already
did you are you entertaining it or
absolutely not
i mean i feel like i'm capable of
like i said producing my own sound um
i got my team so it's like i don't think
i can ever
be assigned to another artist is it
how important is it for you like if
there's an artist that's watching this
that doesn't that only knows how to do
the artist's part the singing the
writing
like what's the importance of having all
that other [ __ ]
like is it freedom like what is like
because you because anybody i feel like
if they really apply themselves they can
learn how to record themselves
you know they can like mixing and
mastering those are things you just just
watching youtube yeah i mean for one
it's going to save you money of course
and for two you want to just be hands on
with your creativity
like once when somebody else put a hand
in it then it's
not 100 yours no more which is not a bad
thing to collaborate of course but
you want to be able to know you know
fully i feel like in 2020 man
with no touring and [ __ ] a lot of
artists need to start
they gotta bring their their costs down
because the live show [ __ ] is
crazy like you bring their costs down
yeah cause
as far as like what features no no yeah
well that no i mean like
there's a lot of artists who depend so
much on the road that they might want to
learn how to record themselves
so they could save some money because
the the the live show game is like
it's crazy because it'll probably be
back to normal by the time it's going to
make sense for you to like headline some
[ __ ]
man i can't wait till i can perform
that's the one thing that
i haven't been able to do yet just
headline my own show
i feel like right now it's the perfect
time but everything locked down right
now
it's like the like okay we got to go to
the roxy tonight
because he sold it out exactly two days
in a row and he's gonna have all the
special guests
yeah that is crazy and you know that's
like a moment every
la artist has they got that roxy show
that's like yo
you got to go through that tunnel to get
to the next level and then and then you
get the palladium one like a year later
if you're doing the right thing i
remember that specifically with like
that
like that first rowdy show yeah was so
crazy i was huge were you that were you
did you go to that
i'm not i didn't yeah that [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] was like okay
this is special um what
with with the coronavirus [ __ ] has that
like
personally affected you like any any
sort of like um
my grandma died from that [ __ ] so uh
passed away from that too
damn sorry to hear that bro yeah man
[ __ ] is really out here on
their conspiracy theory [ __ ] like it's
fake i'm like
bro yeah i'll take it very serious as
well but yeah not um
as far as my workflow everything been
the same cause i record at the house
anyway
and i'm i'm not really out and about
like that unless
you know duty calls but everything been
the same
what about like the music video [ __ ]
like what cause it felt like the first
couple months
people were like kind of scared to shoot
videos out here i definitely got turned
down by a couple of directors
like early on now i feel like it's like
[ __ ] it we're doing it
yeah we pushing through right now there
was [ __ ] shooting videos like
on
like g eazy and jack harlow had a whole
entire video that was just people on
skype
i was like bro you could have just
waited like 30 more days and then
everybody would have chilled
right i got a video shoot tomorrow
matter of fact
oh you do yeah is it a solo joint yeah
i'm off the ep yeah which record
uh be alone fire yeah ep special man
it's it's something that i think is like
it's it's it's like the it backed up the
hype you know what i'm saying because
like i said a lot of people talking
about you but they just press play on
that it's like
oh i get it now yeah that's fire the
response been crazy like
i've been putting out a bunch of songs
singles and then of course i put out
the uh tape with beano but people was
anticipating like what can you do by
yourself
yeah so i feel like yeah like you said
it lived up to
its expectations are you a smoker man
nah no smoke no are you a drinker
sometimes occasionally what is your vice
my vice
all right well he don't want to have it
he said i had me to baby size down julia
oh i know they came back from the liquor
store with these i'm like what am i
supposed to do with this bro it looks
like a bottle of potion from a witch
this looks like somebody tried to
[ __ ] give me mouse ears or some [ __ ]
bro
no but what's your advice i don't know
uh
we all got vices bro my advice
i don't know probably some weird [ __ ]
like eating late oh that's everybody
welcome to my life you see this belly
bro [ __ ] i eat late i feel like i can't
go to sleep unless i eat which is a
horrible thing
i know but [ __ ] i mean yeah welcome to
my life
yeah so that i guess that is a vice food
yeah i'm a fat [ __ ] yeah that's fair
i mean at least you didn't say like some
kind of weird ass like category on
pornhub
i have come on man i don't know man come
on man
you when you said i got a weird one i
was like oh [ __ ]
this might get crazy um how many
records would you say you have for your
album
and is that is this something that we're
gonna get next year or towards the end
of this year
nah it's definitely gonna be next year
um
i really wanted to put out six tape two
before this year ended
but um definitely want to put out the
the deluxe before that so
so is the six tape too you think that's
something that's even like
possible before the end of the year yeah
but the only thing
for that is like i can't really speak on
it entirely because you know i'm only
one half of it of course
but yeah if it was up to me matter of
fact we gonna make it happen
there you go you just spoke on both yeah
um who's another artist that you would
love to do like
or like a just a full collab project
with that you have great chemistry with
um i wouldn't even want to do a collab
tape with anybody else honestly that's
fire yeah
nobody else huh adele the adele tape
i wouldn't even want to do it with a
deal it'll be called like 29 or
something
how would you i just need like one or
two with a dev just
one feature just one feature just to
get me a powder there one time yeah
that'd be yeah
that'd be pretty crazy what about ghost
writing is that something that
you writing for other artists is that
something that people are starting to
try to get at you more to do or
yeah i mean i'm i've definitely been in
a couple writing camps i actually
wrote a song on a new scooby-doo movie
uh the one in that car just came out
yeah okay yeah i watched it co-wrote one
with jack harlow um
shout out devo dave oh shout out to devo
devo is [ __ ]
just salute bro he's he's a good dude
and he's running he's killing [ __ ] right
now
he throw me so many alley oops it's
crazy
they will solid so so but but are you
like starting to is that like even
something you're like interested in
doing
yeah i definitely like writing for other
artists yeah
yeah i feel like that's just the whole
other side of the hustle like yo your
bag on the publishing side could be
bigger than anything else
nah it's definitely fire to hear your
lyrics
no matter what the channel is what kind
of [ __ ]
movies were you watching growing up like
what's your favorite movie of all time
that's a good question i'd probably say
um hangover that's number one huh
just just for the simple fact the first
time i watched it it was like the
funniest movie
oh for sure the first time you watched
hangover yeah yeah yeah that's like
it was a different type of comedy not
the first yeah it was it was
there was like a lot of [ __ ] going on in
that movie
yeah it was never it was never a dead
moment
hangover is the other movie that was
like that for me was
old school nah
that one wasn't like that that was fire
too no it was funny but it wasn't old
school bro
this full the movie starts with him
walking in on his wife getting
gang-banged bro
that's [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] frank the
tank
and then friday when i was a little kid
when i first watched friday i remember
it vividly
and i was trying i thought i was chris
tucker for like seven years as a child
yeah that's a classic yeah yeah
anyway well look uh the ep is out it's
called no love lost
and i think um
the deluxe right around the corner
the deluxe is it gonna be like a whole
nother album cause that's what people
are doing now i'm so confused by the
deluxe thing i know it's like a way to
like stretch your album sales
but like the baby dropped 10 songs on
his like 10 new songs i'm like bro
that's a [ __ ] album
right now i mean i don't plan to drop
like 10 songs at the end of the day
it's still an ep so it's kind of
unconventional what i'm doing already
because not like
like a deluxe toy ep don't even really
make sense technically it would be an
album then
right but um yeah i'm just gonna add
about like four to
five songs and then probably remix a
couple of them
so your only advice i'm just i just
haven't i don't i want to know that
you're like a bad person too
no i'm i'm the coolest person ever i
can't do it man just give me some water
do you get like ever gamble or anything
i just feel like you're the nicest
sweetest guy i've met in this chair in a
long time
we just had soda baby here and it was
interesting he was falling asleep
i'm cool i'm respectable i stand on
integrity
i don't do too much out the out the norm
i mean
i mean obviously you left your music
speak for yourself but yeah that's crazy
you what about us
like a not even like a strip club i mean
i indulge in
you know strip clubs of course but it's
not like i gotta go to the strip club
right right right right well hey you
have you subscribed to any only fans
accounts
no no
none have you thought about it because
you know you'll be on instagram
and then you'll be like oh [ __ ] who is
this and then you'd be like oh [ __ ] i
could just pay
4.99 and just see her naked right now
what's the point of doing that no no i
haven't done it either
i'm just saying like i'm not i'll try to
clean it up now
all right no i haven't [ __ ] that i ain't
giving no [ __ ] my money i'm married
no but like you know i'm just curious
like you know have you thought about it
because i mean i've obviously thought
about it
i'd be like wait this [ __ ] gotta only
fans what's the girl's name uh
um fata rosa acosta has the only fans
did you think about this before or after
the marriage after
i was like should i give my money to
rosa acosta no it'll come up on the
credit card statement and my wife will
be like you would you
13.99 on only fans what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you i couldn't do you can't
write that off on your taxes man
so you're not spending money that you
can't write off media research
ah media research you might have to uh
subscribe to knowledge plan
hey you spent some money on them [ __ ]
shoes though there's alexander mcqueen
some things
those things are are
not on only fans but he's got him on the
mcqueen's anyway go get the ep man
um hopefully you say by october we'll
get the uh end of october we'll get the
ep or the uh
deluxe yep and then next year the album
and before 2021 six tape two
yep okay that's the timeline that's
gotta be the
okay yeah there it is and russ will be
on the deluxe
he's killing me over here i gave him all
the all the gems huh there it
last